so now you know where fragments are used
and where we're going to use them in our
app you're probably starting to ask why
use fragments at all if we want to group
UI components couldn't we just create a
view group on or maybe a reusable XML
our definition yes but the real power in
fragments goes beyond grouping UI
elements they allow us to fully
modularize our activities including the
lifecycle events they receive in the app
state that they maintain fragments were
first introduced in honeycomb to solve a
particular problem honeycomb was the
first Android release to support tablets
and it turned out the best way for most
apps to create a great tablet UI was to
put two or more of their phone
activities alongside each other for
example if you had a phone app that
started with a list activity like this
which you then clicked an item would
open a detail activity like this one
what we call a master detail flow a good
tablet UI would put them side by side
like this functionally clicking item on
this list now replaces this activity on
the right rather than starting a new one
as it would have done here on the phone
now unfortunately Android didn't always
support embedding activities within
other activities at least it didn't
until we introduced fragments now if you
just look at the UI elements you could
be excused for thinking that you could
achieve much the same thing using an
activity that was built using view
groups and layouts without bothering
with fragments which is true up to a
point but they did have to pass through
all of the activity lifecycle events
manage the state of each piece of the UI
keep track of the state of each of the
portions as they changed and remember
which screen elements were on screen at
any given time in order to maintain app
state all of which is exactly what the
fragment manager does for you when you
use fragments and that lets you take a
step back and treat each fragment as
though it were a mini activity for
example in the world of activities you
start one activity from the other and
that transaction is recorded on the back
stack so hitting the back button will
undo that transaction and bring the
first activity to the front now the same
thing can happen with fragment
transactions in this
case rather than starting a new activity
we simply replace the list fragment with
the detail fragment and then the back
button will undo that transaction and
reverse it so in theory you could really
take any app with multiple activities
and replace it with a single activity
that's host to multiple fragments